I think it's gonna be interesting
because I talk a lot I can't shut up
I've always been really intrigued by the
idea of silence as someone that does a
lot of talking I think people are gonna
be uncomfortable I think that's gonna
make me uncomfortable and then I'm not
gonna know how to respond even when I
have strep throat I still find ways to
talk how many do we have right now I
could not communicate something easily
whatsoever not even to save my life I
could tell by the fourth when he finally
got it right
he's very exacerbated with me
turn-key people as the meal went on the
waiter stopped talking and the shows up
yet the matter
no I don't think that was not too hard
I don't think it was overbearing I feel
like every gesture now is catalogs like
I have a dictionary of gestures
it was a lot harder than I thought to
not speak at all I think I think a lot
more now about how I use words and when
I am so relieved I felt like there were
so many things that I left unsaid
because I just had no way of
communicating it I think this did show
me what it's like to really listen to
people more I think I'm definitely more
of tuned now to other people's nonverbal
cues biggest thing that I learned is how
lonely you can feel surrounded by so
many people but you still feel like
you're in this place where nobody can
reach you I think what this taught me
about listening was how to really hone
in on what the person I was speaking to
it really means I think overall I've
learned that the ability to speak when
you want and how you want is truly
powerful and it's not something I would
be giving up anytime soon